before we get started we want to remind
you that good mythical evening is
happening again on september 1st this is
the r rated version of good mythical
morning if you are an adult
and you feel like you're ready for it it
could be a lot of fun if you're if
you're into that type of thing
you know it gets a little explicit it
gets a little off the rails good
mythical evening.com it's exclusively on
moment house live streaming ticketed
event
[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits the podcast
where two lifelong friends talk about
life for a long time i'm rhett and i'm
link this week at the round table of dim
lighting
we're going on a verbal vacation
and to hear you talk about it
last week
it sucked but you know what it's better
to have a good story than a good time
and you know as i've gone through
uh
all the experiences that i have had and
then tried to figure out how i'm going
to talk about them i have realized that
it was all worth it just for this moment
you know like whatever i went all right
don't have everything pressure on
yourself
i just i'm just saying that like i just
feel like i don't know how entertaining
it's gonna be but i think it's gonna be
very cathartic for me just to
get it all out there oh but i want to
give a quick interjection reminder good
mythical evening the second one is
happening september 1st exclusively on
moment house it's a live ticketed event
r-rated version of gmm if you're an
adult
grab yourself a ticket at good mythical
evening.com all right
again man whenever whenever something
goes
sideways it's great to have a podcast
where you know it's like well now i now
i know what i can talk about i tried to
keep that in mind the whole time you did
i do think that's good it's good to not
be in the moment but to be kind of like
in performance mode and i'll just go
ahead and get started why not right yeah
i mean but i i will say last night lily
asked me
i mean
i guess she was prompted by observing me
like she keeps watching you like christy
and i were in bed and she comes up she
comes upstairs
because she you know she's got a job
i heard about it got a summer job
so uh she she comes home she's got her
uniform on it's i'm so proud of her she
comes in the room we're asking her about
everything and then like i was like
totally tucked into bed
and then she's like
is that how you sleep dad
i'm glad that she's turning out to be
normal and i'm like i'm just thankful
for that i'm like yeah and i was like
you just use that pillow i was like you
haven't heard about my physical therapy
pillow yes this is the only this little
log is the only thing i use and and like
so you like and she's like so you sleep
like this and it was just like like a
like a smushed frog on a highway like on
its back
and i was like yeah and she was like why
are you so weird yeah lily's got her
head i'm like for your entertainment
lily she was like
really i was like yeah yeah i live to
entertain you i got to hang out with
lily
for reasons that we'll get into in a
little bit
right um
me and jessie and lily and her friend
actually got to go to a concert together
yeah um i'm not happy about it and i was
but i'm i'm okay i'm happy for you lily
is uh
she's got her head on straight uh she
understands that her dad is weird it's
the thing that is important is if you
have a weird dad
you can get lost in the weirdness
and lose perspective or you can uh
understand the weirdness and just
maintain some groundedness and i think
that's what she's done she she loves me
for it
you know she's going to keep me around
for a long time
um
okay i'll get started because there's
multiple steps to this it wasn't just
one trip to one place it was there was
multiple things that happened
so the fir so we were planning on going
to uh
uh north carolina as like the main part
of this vacation it's like go back to
north carolina see family also uh
is is working on this this uh you know
this
vacation place slash airbnb we don't
know exactly what it's gonna be that we
the vacation home that we've we've
bought there and so she's like doing her
design thing on it
and
so we're like okay we're going to make
the most of the time there and stay near
the the cabin
but
we've got a little bit of time in this
two week window where we can also just
do like a little family vacation let's
just do something simple like drive to
santa barbara beautiful place that's
only like 90 minutes away from us
uh and it would just be me and shepherd
i mean me and jesse and shepard i i'm
not gonna put shepherd's second
jesse
and i and then our son shepard
uh and locke may or may not show up
because he's hanging out with his friend
and they're doing things and not you
know i don't know exactly how it's gonna
go
so jesse's been very busy i've been very
busy uh so we did not do as much of uh
let's just say like vetting and research
on this particular airbnb that we were
going to stay at all we knew is that it
was an incredible location like right on
the beach one of those situations where
you've got waves literally at high tide
crashing into the structure that you
were sleeping in at night you know what
i'm saying i mean you can't go wrong
with that unless the house falls into
the ocean but that's not my problem
unless i'm in the house at the time
sounds like you could be uh that's a
wonderful thing about renting
of course the whole time i was there i
was thinking man what would be like to
own this place i'd be constantly worried
about it falling into the ocean right
so
all right there's a couple of things
that lead up to the vacation where i you
know
we had some pictures
some old pictures that we were getting
down from storage to go through and scan
some
for a james james and the shame related
thing that we're doing now it turns out
we're not even using these particular
photos uh at this point
you'll understand weeks from now what
i'm talking about but
so i'm carrying big things not just this
big thing of pictures and getting all
this crap down but i'm also like getting
the suitcases and carrying them down the
stairs i carry jesse's suitcase whenever
i do this kind of thing often before a
vacation i end up
unintentionally stressing out my lower
back i always thought that i was hurting
my lower back before i went on vacation
because it was like a transition and i
was trying to relax and that may be part
of it but i think it's because i'm just
carrying a lot of [ __ ] right before you
go on vacation
so
when we arrive at the place i'm kind of
like i'm already in a little bit of a
bad mood because i'm like man my back is
hurting me and i know it's going to take
48 hours before i can paddleboard which
is the thing i'm excited about is just
being right there on the beach and being
able to go out there and
catch some waves man you know what i'm
saying or at least just paddle around
like an old guy
sure
but we arrive at the airbnb
and
we walk in and the first thing that we
all notice not just the tall guy is that
the ceilings are
um
low
now i will say
in the airbnb description it did say
there there are this is like the base
not it's the bottom floor of like a two
unit thing and it's an old place and the
ceilings are a little bit low in places
there's kind of there's some beams or
something we didn't read it closely
enough
okay what i'm saying is that if you are
over five nine
wow
uh you would have had to duck to miss
these beams that are all throughout the
house
also the bathroom seemed like it was
made for hobbits
and all this was taken with like wide
angle lenses on the airbnb
listing so we had really no idea it was
as extreme as it was
but then i just started walking around
they didn't have like a red stick for
reference which like they have here in
the gmm studio a six foot seven tall
stick right which stands in for you we
need to ship the red stick ahead of time
and have somebody go around and take
pictures with it
but
jesse begins taking pictures of me
uh and you know my wife is a bit of a um
she's she knows what she's doing on the
social media if you follow her you know
this
and so she was like i've got to make
this into a post and she was like let me
just take some pictures of you and the
only thing she said in her tweet was
just arrived at our airbnb with like
three or four pictures of me standing
there with my head completely gone
like behind behind a beam
and
i don't know how many hundreds of
thousands of likes or tweet has at this
point but it is the most viral tweet
i've ever been in like personal
proximity to i mean i've been on twitter
since
i don't know well over a decade yeah we
have a lot of professional tweets and i
am a relatively internet famous person
never had a viral tweet
my wife just farts one out
of course as i told her i was in it
of course you couldn't see my face
your bottom half she did not tag me
um
so anyway
while she got a viral tweet out of it
which was pretty awesome
we immediately began to
i had taken all this stuff down these
stairs like you had to come downstairs
to get to the unit where you could go in
the side and go around and get in there
and i might settled in and she's like
mad she's happy about the tweet but
she's mad about the situation
and she says
i just think we should go we should just
go somewhere else like we're not gonna
be able you're not gonna be able to
enjoy yourself you you're gonna be
ducking around this thing and
you know and also it's only one bathroom
this is this is something that was in
the listing that we just didn't really
look at
and
uh the it's technically it's got like
four bunk beds that are outside in the
living room area kind of
so shepherd was going to be sleeping in
this bunk bed that's kind of out in the
open and then sharing a bathroom with us
and 13 year old needs privacy if you
know what i mean you know what i'm
saying
and um
so you can kind of tell that he's a
little bit antsy and then jesse's like
we just let's just try to find like a
hotel like we can get our money back for
the i'm like we've already moved all our
stuff in i'm the tall one i'm the one
who should be complaining and i'm not
let's just try to enjoy ourselves
not a great way to start a vacation yeah
yelling at each other about how you need
to try to enjoy yourself
and she could she couldn't think of
other ways to like continue to make more
viral tweets i mean it's kind of like
you you go into that you dig that well
one time yep you know what i'm saying
so
um
but i was like there's a lot to love
about this the location is beautiful
there's a freaking hot tub on the deck
out there overlooking the beach and i
immediately got into it there you go by
myself know when i got in there with me
no low beams over it well
you're seated but i will say the deck
from the
upper part is like over you so there's
no like no sun and that was another
thing that wasn't great it would have
been nice to be on the top wow you're in
you guys are
you know if you care this much you kind
of need to read the the description yeah
well that sounds like lesson learned
every everything you're complaining
about you immediately say it was in the
description i'm just going to point that
out it wasn't you know how they don't
they don't they're not going to that's
the art to airbnb they
you've got to interpret everything as a
worst case scenario i mean if they
mention it in any way and it can be
interpreted as negative then the reality
is it's very negative you have to be
committed to reading all the reviews and
here's the thing i look for in reviews
about that there was only two reviews
yeah two reviews
one of the things i've learned to look
for in airbnb reviews is somebody at
least one person saying something good
about the mattresses because that's
that's a big thing for me it's like
if you don't have a good mattress that
could suck of course i bring my own
pillow right now i bring my own pillow
small enough for me to pack right mom
you know that for you
uh that's a little dip the bed was okay
the bed wasn't good
um
but anyway so things were slightly
charged you might say
uh a couple of days in
shepherd is already he's like kind of
bored because
he can't like get he can't get into a
personal space you know what i mean and
it's like i was like yeah i hate that
for him
uh because he like likes to get on and
like
you know talk to his boys and play games
and stuff and
so he's getting a little bit amped up
the tv like we wanted the first night we
wanted because we were all caught up we
wanted to watch the stranger things
finale but
the tv remote didn't work
oh you're doing that thing where you're
trying to find a button on the back of
the television just turn it on and also
can i use my phone for this couldn't
connect to the sonos sound system
so it's like
there was a lot of things that were kind
of falling apart and making it stressful
and making it difficult to enjoy now
these are meanwhile remember privileged
problems i was in hawaii remember how
good of a time you have a great time
best vacation ever best vacation ever
now so
we have some good experiences had a few
good meals i did eventually get out on
the water
um but then
i'd say four nights just like a five
five night thing to get kind of before
we went to north carolina the fourth
night
like jesse we have to go through these
pictures
you brought the pictures and uh and and
so i said i have a system in mind for
how i like to go again what i'm thinking
when i approach this is
we have a bunch of pictures from the
past
before we had digital cameras
so this is uh lots of from college from
after college from early marriage
and
i'm like i want to be able to enjoy
these photos and look through them so my
idea is if we scan the ones that we want
to scan
then we can enjoy them
jesse's expectation that she brought to
this process
we're going to enjoy this right now why
can't we just enjoy it right now we're
looking at these pictures let's enjoy it
right now yeah
and
um
we clashed
oh again tension's already high
but we clash in in this situation
and it ended up getting uh like we got
into
a pretty big argument about it because i
was unrelenting and she was unrelenting
because i was like i'm going to keep
doing my system because i want to get
done with this i don't want to do this
tomorrow night you're making a scan pile
and she's making a memory
yeah i want to make the memory in the
future and she's like oh look at us so
and so so it's like a romantic
opportunity i'm like yeah but i that's
later
that's later right now is the system
yeah
and i let me also add two other factors
that are going into the stress level
being high
as you know
we rarely take an actual vacation so i'm
you know i'm on vacation but i'm taking
meetings i'm joining meetings i'm doing
zoom meetings i'm i'm doing emails we're
continuing to be
bosses to some degree if it's the
meetings that we couldn't miss yeah
there's some as always it ebbs and flows
but we were kind of in a season at that
that week especially where it's just
like some uncertainty about some things
developing projects and stuff that are
just kind of like you can't get out of
your mind so like uh unresolved things
that were kind of stressing me out and
then of course i'm trying to get ready
to announce this james and the shane
project and also i'm
doing a lot of it on my own getting
ready for this launch and doing a lot of
the technical back-end and even the
design of some of the stuff and so
there's just a lot right so it's like
tensions are high and everything is
adding to the tension so we kind of
snapped
and went to bed angry
oh okay
we wake up in the morning
and i'm like hey
let's take a walk on the beach
let's try to hit the reset button clean
slate we are in a beautiful location
especially if we're not in the house
good idea if we get outside we forget
about the low beams
you know we forget about the one
bathroom forget about our sun
i hope this worked
it didn't
um
we get out on the beach beautiful we're
walking
and then
we begin talking
and we
kind of pick up right where we left off
but the pictures i don't know how it
started but i
i thought this is an opportunity to
clear this stuff up and and i and i
tried to kind of come into the
conversation with someone i was like i
feel like we brought different
expectations into this process
but we didn't really get to talk about
that
because we kind of just ended up
restating exactly what our positions
were the night before and at that point
nobody budged
we went from a couple walking on the
beach to just two people walking on the
beach
in a line
in a line that grew
she was in front of you she was in front
yeah yeah yeah uh
and at one point i would just her legs
must have been moving fast in front of
you two people on a beach or like a man
following a woman
on a beach not sure what's gonna happen
there but like she was a good 50 yards
is what we kind of settled
you know oh wow two people walking on
the beach i was like eventually
we're to get to a place where we can't
go any further because she's on
california and it's on her to turn
around
she's got to turn around at some point
so she does at which point we meet and
then we start walking together and then
it was a good opportunity to have that
space we began talking in a calm
demeanor and we actually at least she
didn't turn around and like slap me you
were like 50 yards you see her she's
like picking up speed picking up speed
she just like
tackles you oh well i'm a big man
um
so
we ended up getting to a good place and
talking about how when we collaborate on
things like that we have to state what
our
expectations and intentions are and if
we are bringing very different
expectations and attentions to something
then we need to
make some adjustments it was really the
com
everything
accumulating
you know as with most
big fights that are about nothing it's
really
everything else which you've outlined
true
you know um but this was also the day
uh that we were going to go whale
watching
whale watching and i'm going to tell you
all the right time of year oh it's the
right time buddy let me tell you how
right it is i'm going to tell you all
about well watching how that may be the
thing that completely redeemed the
entire vacation
in a second
but first
don't you have a podcast yeah i'm doing
it man
i'm just listening to you
no but you have another podcast i have
another one i've got a couple yeah i've
got like three or four in the works no i
just got i don't want any more podcasts
uh dispatchers from myrtle beach is
going good if you haven't checked it out
check it out i know people are asking
for a video version the time's not right
for that but uh we will keep it in mind
so
if you only listen if you can watch
i would just ask for you to give it a
shot
you know just go over there to wherever
you get your podcast and just listen for
30 minutes listen to episode one if you
don't like that you won't like any of
the other ones but
i think it's one of the funniest things
that i think that mythical has ever made
thank you
and i end up finding myself not i can't
take credit for it it's mostly your dad
but i so
i
i end up
even the other night when we were at a
party at my house and you were there i
ended up just playing
i just held up my phone and played a a
clip from mythical pods for everybody
because i just want people i'm just like
you have to understand you got right you
got to understand what's going on here
like you need to check this out like
yeah this is an in this is entertainment
pure entertainment
so
go listen to it there's a lot of there's
a lot of levels to it you know there's
i feel like it's people people describe
it as raunchy at times people describe
it as wholesome and usually they
describe those things at the same time
where else can you get that yeah right
well
there's a certain part of hallmark
stores
oh really yeah yeah that's kind of what
that's kind of what dispatches from
myrtle beach is wherever you get your
podcast all right listen to it
okay well watching
sure okay so uh we had set this up ahead
of time we knew that we were supposed
it's on you know thankfully i have uh
people in my life like cara in this
situation who uh put this on my calendar
and tell me where i need to be and when
i need to be there
10 am because you get on a boat it's
what it said and so i'm like well
you know 10 a.m is probably like when
you're supposed to like kind of arrive
and they start telling you what you need
to be ready for or whatever you know
wrong
uh we get we we go through the harbor
gate there in the santa barbara harbor
at 9 59. and you know you have to like
get a ticket and there's a woman at the
gate
and i didn't know where i was supposed
to go so i was just like we're going
whale watching she's like oh you better
hurry
because i they'd leave at 10 o'clock
sharp oh
so at that point i'm like oh crap we go
this is first of all all the tensions
that had been built our backs are back
and we're trying to find a parking space
in this giant lot and i'm supposed to be
on this far end of the thing to get on
the boat and that was when i hit the
steering wheel and said i hate this
vacation wow uh
yep so my definitely the vacation's
fault yep my my wife and my son
thankfully only one of my children was
with me at the time we'll forever
remember that i'm sure uh-huh
um
so i said i'm gonna drop you guys off
you run to the boat you tell him i'm
parking and tell him to wait
so drop shepard and jesse off they're
running towards the boat
i'm trying to find i can't find a spot
in the lot that i'm at next to the boat
so i have to go out into another lot
i park i'm in flip-flops y'all
jessie calls me
she says
the captain said you need to run
the captain is now giving me messages
yeah you tell the captain i'm in
flip-flops
well i listen to the captain and first
of all have you just noticed that like
as you get older and then you have to
run for a reason and you're like damn
running ain't easy yeah like jogging
okay six months stretch beforehand
sprinting in like good running shoes
would be difficult
yeah for more than a couple like 10 to
20 yards
but running 300 yards in flip-flops
i was making so much noise
people probably thought there's
fireworks going off pre-fourth of july
i ended up making it uh literally the
the guy like the the not the captain but
the
one of the crew was like
well
all right you're lucky
basically as i go up the little stairs
that they had set there and he
immediately removes them as i get on the
boat
was everybody on the boat looking at you
yeah
i mean quite an entrance they heard me
coming from at least 200 yards away
what is that that's a tall man running
in flip-flops
um
so the first thing i notice as we settle
in is that everyone else has a lot more
clothes on
nobody else is wearing flip-flops and
shorts
they're bundled up i'm talking
pants and like
those
puffy jet puffy jackets oh gosh with
hoods
yeah i'm like i should have read about
this
now i do have a hoodie on
because i was like oh we're going out on
a boat it was like 80 degrees in santa
barbara which is pretty warm for santa
barbara it's like it can't be that much
cooler out on a boat
it was really
the wind chill but also just the sea air
and where did you get where did the boat
go out channel island so right in
between santa cruz and whatever the
other island is right next to it not
santa cruz santa cruz california santa
cruz island so off the coast of santa
barbara and off the coast of this whole
part of california there's the channel
islands which technically catalina is
part of that island chain it's just
further south i'm gonna go scuba diving
out there yeah it's a beautiful place
and there's an incredible history about
the islands and pretty sad history about
the native people who were out there and
how they were like moved to the shore to
build the mission
when the christians showed up they made
them all leave and go work on the
mainland it was it's pretty horrible um
but
it's a beautiful place and the reason
that it is that's a small price for you
to think you're saving their souls uh
don't say you but you mean them yeah i
know what you mean
um
so the
the the cool thing about this place is
that there's a lot of whale traffic i
mean this is what whale watching is all
about you go to where the whales are on
the inside of the islands or on the
outside of the island uh especially in
between the two islands okay something
about what's happening with the wildlife
at that place
basically makes it like a feeding ground
now he said uh we should you know we'll
probably see some humpbacks i've never
seen a whale i never seen a whale for
some reason i thought it had to be like
winter
january i didn't think it could be july
the season is most of the year there's
different whale types species that will
be there is what it looked like but like
may to sometime in the fall
is probably the best time not only for
the weather but also because this time
of year is when the blue whales show up
largest animal
on the planet
really largest energy
now he said as we were going out he said
we might see a blue whale i will say
it's not common there's only 15 000 blue
whales in the world at this point which
just
that's less than like that's less than
you would see at a basketball game you
know what i'm saying like this is
i've never seen a whale out of
basketball
all exactly all of the whales in the
world
uh the blue whales and wilder wouldn't
be able to fit inside like the you know
the crypto dome just because of whatever
they call it because they're bigger than
people but just to give you an idea of
how many people yeah yeah it's um
sad
um
so
we uh it took us a while to get out
there like it's miles off of the coast
and you're going pretty like an hour on
a big more than an hour i think maybe 90
minutes to get out to the location one
of the things that we did see on the way
out there
um when we would venture out onto the
deck and freeze our asses off uh
because there's like an inside area
where you could sit and close and
there's like a snack bar pretty cool
dolphin pods now we've seen dolphins
you've seen dolphins
we've surfed with dolphins
but when you get a couple miles out from
shore the dolphin pods are enormous i'm
talking hundreds of dolphins
hundreds is overwhelming
beside the boat and then they see the
boat and they come swim with it and they
jump up you know they're smart they're
they they they know so much
that we don't that we don't know that
they know and
they're like showing off for us and
stuff and i'm like this is pretty cool
okay they
this horrible vacation is getting a
little bit better what if we just see a
whale and at that point we get closer
we're on our way out there and the guy
comes the captain comes on the loud
speaker and says okay we've spotted a
whale looks like we've got a juvenile
humpback
they don't use terms like
port and stern and stuff because we're
all idiots and he's just on the left
front side of the boat
you know he just uses things that
everybody can understand
uh it's still a ways off
and i was kind of amazed at how well i
go out there and i see this blowhole
from what felt like several hundred
yards and this guy somehow knows this is
a humpback a juvenile humpback he's
probably got binoculars but also maybe a
radar he's seen quite he's seen quite a
lot of uh of whales
and sure enough we get out there and i
see
and i and i made it put on your
flip-flops we're gonna run to the whale
i made a commitment that i was not going
to use my camera because i was like i
want to be in the moment and what's i
mean
if people want to see a video of a whale
they can get one that like national
geographic made not rhett you know what
i mean
yeah so i'm like i want to see this i
want to be in the moment so right now as
you're talking about this for the video
version we're going to cut to like some
really amazing oh whale footage hold
your horses because i get to a video
hold your whales
uh so
we get up there and we see this humpback
and it was a juvenile so i mean i don't
know this thing was probably 20 feet
long it's still
it's a large animal it's like the
largest animal i've been close to next
to the boat like a like a dolphin would
be no no no
they the whales don't come up and maybe
they do at times but these whales were
not like hey we're going to come show
off for you they're more just like i'm
doing my thing i'm not scared of you and
so they get the boat they move the boat
kind of close they turn the boat and
they move close to the whale once you
spot it and what happens is these whales
come up and they do their thing they
stay near their surface and they're
doing their blowhole thing and then they
take a deep dive and their tail comes up
whoo
just like the commercials
and they go down and then he's like okay
we're going to wait seven to nine
minutes now
because once they do the tail thing
they're going deep they don't always do
the tail thing but they if they do the
same thing in nine minutes
seven minutes exactly later the guy says
okay it's been seven minutes keep an eye
out
and then as he's finishing the sentence
here it comes again because they they're
predictable they go down seven and nine
minutes and this one apparently was a
sevener
and it comes up in the same spot no it's
it he's like oh it's on the right side
of the boat and so everybody goes to the
right side of the boat and then we see
it do its thing
so we saw two humpbacks we ended up
seeing like a mother and a juvenile it
was really cool
then we he says all right we're going to
keep going because we need to get to the
area between the two islands which is
where
if we're going to see a blue whale
this is where we would see it
so we start getting close to this spot
and
the guy comes on this the the
loudspeaker is like
okay well we've seen a whale it's pretty
far off we're not exactly sure what
species it is
uh we're gonna we're gonna keep moving
just keep your eyes out on the left
front side of the boat
so
we start going and then
we get to again you kind of like from a
hundred yards away you see this thing
come up and you see this blowhole he
says it's a juvenile blue whale what
i'm like oh brother
we're seeing a blue whale
we get
up close to it
boom boom it's doing the same thing that
the humpback's doing like coming up
blowing breathing
and then he says before this happens he
says now it's really on you first of all
he says you can kind of he's got some
energy in his voice because this is a
big moment for him he's like this is we
don't always see blue whales he's trying
to let these people get our normies on
the boat understand what they're
experiencing
like this is a once-in-a-lifetime
opportunity and he says and usually he
says this thing's gonna dive in a second
they usually don't do the he had a
technical term for it they don't show
the tail that's what i say
show the tail in the same way every time
they use it's less common for blue
whales to do that at that moment the
thing comes up shows its tail yes and
goes down
and i'm just like i'm you know i'm
totally dadding out i'm grabbing [ __ ]
i'm saying it showed his tail son just
for you what yeah how long
was this juvenile juvenile i would i
would say uh 30 feet or so that's a big
ass thing right
it goes then but then at that point says
we've spotted an adult blue whale what
no
but also when the thing goes down he's
like okay the blue will be down from 10
to 12 minutes
10 to 12.
um
okay so i got to see and i was pretty
close
relatively to this thing to the juvenile
but then
the adult comes up
and it's within
50 yards
40 yards of the boat wow
and at that point i was like i've
already seen a blue whale i've seen a
blue whale do the tail thing
i think i'm going to film this thing
because now i can now i can say
i was there and i enjoyed this and let
me just show you right now what i ended
up getting
this is of course we know this is going
to be national geographic footage we all
understand that
but we're gonna let rhett have his
moment this is an adult
he's zooming in here
wow look he's going keeps going he's
going and look
also
does the tail
so slow can you believe that i mean i
know that again i don't have a sense of
scale geographic would have like a you
know you'd have a sense of scale
they get to 90 feet long
okay
i've been obsessed with these i i don't
think i've ever explained just my i was
really into whales especially as a kid i
had whale stuffed animals and stuff and
anytime i went to a
like a natural history history museum
i would there would be oh this is the
blue whale skeleton that's hanging in
this room or whatever i was just like i
can't believe that this thing exist
their heart is the size of a volkswagen
bus
pumps one time a minute
it sends that blood all over all right
we're gonna wait 60 seconds for the
heart to be his heart's going to beat
again
um
and like the the dude on the loudspeaker
is just losing it he's like you saw two
blue whales they both did the tail thing
again he's using the technical term i
don't know
bucket
is that the starboard bow yeah he did
and i tipped well
uh and like i go but i'm like i'm like
grabbing my wife and my child and i'm
just like we just experienced this they
don't seem as into it as me this is kind
of the largest living
uh
animal
yeah
yeah
just right there just blowing for us
we go back inside at this point the
guy's like all right now we need to turn
around and get back home
go back inside we sit back down
i look my wife and my child in the face
and i said i [ __ ] love this vacation
turn it around for me
yeah you're uh
it was that easy you're like a you're
like a ship without a moor it's like
you're what's it called you know a ship
without an anchor you're you're just
floundering it's i was in a freezer i
was in a freaking vacation man i was in
a fragile state but we're gonna die this
is the best day ever
i mean seeing a blue whale and seeing a
blue whale do that thing with his tail
like redemption it made it all worth it
uh it really
and as my vacation uh progresses and
things uh
only get worse as we're about to learn
okay i kept holding on to that blue
whale just stuck my hand i just put my
whole body right in its blow hole
up to my waist and just grabbed on and
said this is the thing that i am going
to
hold on to yeah
so that was the next the last day we go
home the next morning uh
high on blue whale fumes uh
me and you have to take a little trip
yep that's when i i just i got back from
hawaii
and then the very next morning we have
to meet up
get on a plane rhett link going to aspen
colorado never been to aspen i was
pretty excited about this this was a
youtube
uh panel
at the aspen ideas fest we were invited
to
share
our perspective
it was live streamed you you might have
caught it um it was
it was quite a little trip you know like
we got there that night we got up the
next day we saw a little bit of aspen
stayed there and did our panel
slept that night got up next morning and
then flew our separate ways so you could
continue to your vacation
and i could go back home uh but yes just
i knew that colorado was a beautiful
place i had been before it
been to vail but i have been during the
winter i never really been to like a ski
town in the summer time and i'd heard
that like oh you got to go to us but in
the summer time and you know this is
you're just halfway to see us this is
like the ultimate rich place you know
what i'm saying like i mean yeah the
real estate is just
insultingly expensive
and we were but it's so incredible like
it's just this incredible spot we walked
around well you the airport is in this
is in the valley and then like you drive
around the valley and you're in aspen
proper within like
i don't know seven minutes
the thing that struck me was that i mean
you've got these like
very aggressively sloped mountains on
every side and of course you can see the
ski slopes even though they're green
just right there and they come right
down to the base of the mountain and
it's the town of asia you can ski right
into it and and the town of aspen was
was established there well before there
were ski resorts there so it like and
it's
it's not just one
road there's like a grid of streets with
all types of
um
long established buildings like man that
bank looks like it was there in the
frontier times
yeah it's kind of a vibe pretty old so
it's like
it's a pretty expansive
old town that still has this kind of
vibe of like
i've been here since i don't know when
it whenever it was established well it's
been there since it was established i
can tell you that for sure and one one
of the highlights for us was we rented
uh
electric bikes we were told
uh you know by robert kinsel the uh
big big man at youtube
who was who was on our panel who we've
gotten to know uh
he was like you need to you need to ride
bikes down the rio grande which i
couldn't have told you that the rio
grande
flew or
flew right through there right through
right through aspen no blue whales um
so we did that and boy i mean
i there's a couple of places i've been
in the world where i felt like i was in
a fairy tale you know what i mean where
it's just this is like this weirdly
curated part of the matrix that's a
little too nice very pristine i mean
right when we got on the bike path
we stopped and we're like oh look at
those mansions right there next to the
creek that leads right here to the river
and i looked at this it was this mansion
built on the side of this slope and then
right next to the house
there was
a waterfall
like a creek that became a waterfall
flowing
like pretty vertically
like right like right next to this yard
waterfall i mean this is next level
stuff
and it's it was it had been curated by a
landscaper but it not been created by
a landscaper right
it's like no i'm gonna build my house
next to this little waterfall
good gracious
it was
it was it was so beautiful that it was
disturbing it was it was almost a little
unsettling yeah um there's no grit
couldn't find any grit
but
we did go to uh
several people had told us that we
needed to go to a store called kimo sabe
which was this like you know wearing the
like cowboy hat and like stetson hat is
a thing that's kind of associated with
western ski towns
and uh this place we went to like this
place makes these incredible hats not i
wasn't planning on buying a hat it
didn't but they like hats boots etc what
and they'll if you if you're willing to
pay like i don't know it might be a
thousand dollars or more for a hat yeah
these are now they'll like
they'll put it on your head and
perfectly size it they'll like like
steam it to like fit your noggin no
matter how wonky your head is right they
can put a hat around it
but we noticed when we walked in that
like five
women in their late 20s
we all had hats on sort of very glammed
up they kind of descend upon you when
you enter the store and begin
asking you to need help
following you around as you go to the
different things
um and i was very intrigued with the
knife section yeah they had this like
total
glass case full of
knives and there's a craftsman i think i
asked her first i was like
what's what's the deal with these knives
well and it's a craftsman from georgia
who makes these knives and she brings
she starts small literally like a small
knife she brings it out and it's like
got this cutting board
that you put this cheese knife that's
about this long about three inches long
about three inches long she puts it on
this little magnet to kind of make it
suspend itself above the the cutting
board
and she's like um the handle of this one
is made from mammoth tooth or something
like that yeah
and it is
twenty nine hundred dollars
all right
okay we're gonna cut some cheese with a
three thousand dollar knife
and she kept going because apparently we
look like we can maybe get knives like
this
yeah i mean
with the twinkle in her eye
she moves on and let me just i'll cut to
the chase eventually she brings us to
a knife that was this long yeah it's
like a three and a half foot knife that
the handle for the knife was the the jaw
of an extinct
fossilized
cave bear i'm talking about the huge
cave bears yeah that were on the north
american plains back in the day
and this knife
was twenty thousand dollars yes
yeah a knife
i don't i don't did she let us touch it
i don't know that she didn't take that
one i think by that point she was saw
the buoys creek was really coming out in
her eyes
oh my goodness look at the jaw on that
she's like i'm not gonna get this one
out for these fools
they're obviously not gonna buy anything
they're just going to look at stuff we
strolled out of there i mean you almost
bought a wallet i thought well a pair of
gloves oh yeah a pair of gloves
after being shown all this so much
leather in there
i was like oh there's a 65
pair of really nice leather gloves we
walked out of there with nothing we did
except this story uh but we had a great
time in aspen now
i was you were gonna go back to los
angeles which i assume that just
happened
a breeze you probably just got on a
plane and just went straight to los
angeles right
no i had to fly through denver
okay but no complications no
complications i on the other hand red
carpet man i continued with uh
my troubles so i was supposed to fly
from aspen to denver you had no troubles
when you were with me you need to know
that denver to raleigh
because you can't fly from aspen to
raleigh
so we get on the runway in aspen
and then the pilot comes over the
loudspeaker a lot of people talking to
me over loudspeakers on this vacation
now that i'm thinking about it i've got
a juvenile
yeah i was having trouble deciphering
between the pilot and the captain which
i guess is the same person in some ways
yep
the pilot comes on the loudspeaker and
says
we've got a problem uh
we're too heavy
we're gonna remove the tallest guy with
the biggest hair everyone start doing
cardio right now uh he said
basically there was a mix-up in this
plane
was a plane that was supposed to fly to
a different location but there was a
mix-up because the night before
a rich person in their private plane
went off of the edge of the runway and
they had to shut the airport down
because the aspen airport is notorious
for like accidents because it's like
this the wind and the short runway and
all this stuff
it's a small airport so
he said we can take off but we have to
be at a certain weight to land and i
have three options i can ask some of you
to leave which i don't want to do
i can um
have somebody come and take fuel
directly out of the plane but that takes
a very long time for some reason
or we can sit on the runway and burn
fuel
this is a great time to just burn jet
fuel in the economy you know this goes
just burn it for the hell of it oh god
and so he comes to that conclusion that
that's what they're going to do they're
going to sit on the road did everybody
vote
like what didn't appear to be a democrat
three options did not appear to be a
democracy
we sit on the runway for 30 minutes
burning fuel and then he has to add an
additional 15 minutes to our route to
denver which would have only been half
an hour he's going to make it 45 minutes
in order to get to the right weight to
land because that's that's when weight
is really an issue is when you're trying
to land
i mean just he should just keep going up
keep gaining altitude icarus that be
but what ended up happening was i missed
my connection because of all this
at which point
uh i ended up getting on another plane
from denver i was gonna go from denver
to houston
houston to raleigh
while we're in the air
going to houston
the pilot comes over the intercom and
says we have a problem
uh houston we have houston has a problem
uh
the houston airport has been closed
due to weather so we are diverting to
dallas
okay
so we land in dallas we land in dallas
and the pilot says okay we don't have
enough fuel
to make it to houston
i know where you could have got some
yeah
right yeah i get abroad in my carry-on
uh so we had to wait for them to fuel
all this stuff takes forever now i'm
thankful that we live in a country which
is
pretty well regulated and so there are
things like lots of paperwork and stuff
that has to be done to make sure that
that's why people don't die in
commercial airline crashes because of
the regulations that's why you die in
private plane crashes a lot if you're
gonna die in a plane crash because of
all this
all this logistics and stuff they have
to do but when you're really wanting to
just get to raleigh
you're just like why can't you just fill
the damn plane up and shut the door
i didn't say that everyone remained
remarkably calm
but i was like this day this flight
trying to get to raleigh is becoming
like a
an analogy for the way my life feels
right now you know what i'm saying like
there was just a lot of again i'm
thinking a lot about the album coming
out too because i was like i'm going to
announce the album
the following week and i don't know how
people are going to think about this and
they're going to think i'm dumb for
doing this like i'm thinking all these
things and i'm more stressed out about
that than i realized the business stuff
that we that we continue to talk about
um
you know just like there's just a lot of
stress in this and then i'm having this
crazy day
we end up flying
okay so yeah so we go from dallas but
he's like now we're going to just fly to
houston so we fly from dallas to houston
okay and then we're going to fly from
houston to raleigh and the the flight to
raleigh gets delayed but actually i'm
thankful it got delayed because i may
not have made it if it didn't get
delayed so anyway i woke up at 5 30 a.m
that day was on four different planes
and my wife picked me up from the
airport in raleigh at like midnight wow
a long day very happy to see my wife
uh and you know when you're really happy
to see your wife or that and you're
going to a hotel room just the two of
you you know what that leads to
oh yeah missionary sex
okay shout out to trevor
on that one yeah
uh from the smosh funeral if you don't
know uh and
one of the things that you'll understand
why i'm explaining this in detail one of
the things that happens when you're
having missionary sex oh god uh is your
faces even though i'm much taller than
my wife i do have a way of getting my
face close to her face
during missionary sex okay okay and i
was able to do that uh it takes a little
flexibility
and some arching of the back
but
i was able to do that and you know we
really had a great reunion
the reason i'm giving you these details
is because i did not know at the time
but my wife had covet
oh
now she told me
did that did that missionary evangelize
the covet
oh she shared it with me all right
uh
she had told me that she had a sore
throat now my wife has told me she's had
a sore throat like a hundred times over
the past couple of years yeah and every
time she thinks she has coveted and
every time she hasn't and so i'm like
you've you're just you just got to north
carolina it's allergies man mm-hmm
whatever like i've never seen a positive
coveted test allergies hate coffee boy
they're really getting a batter up with
all this coffee yeah
um
so
but she wakes up the next day and feels
worse
ends up taking a test
positive i'm like
dang it we had missionary sex we slept
in the same bed
um so i'm basically like man i've
totally been exposed because you are
really really infectious like in the
early stages of covet especially like
right before symptoms hit and as
symptoms are hitting like you know
at least with these latest
varieties is what i was going to say
what is the term
i still have coveted brain strange
because i got it
uh strains isn't it
variance
yeah for getting very simple words which
we'll talk about in a second um
but i'm like
i'm supposed to play golf with my
brother and my dad the next day
okay
and
this was a special golf trip for a
number of reasons
mainly because we were going to play
keith hills country club which is the
country club i grew up next to yeah the
my neighborhood was outside the gate i
didn't grow up in a country club but i
would stop i could walk to the course
you act like it and
the uh the
the course
there's an original 18 holes that
it's so weird how i played that course
so many times growing up that it's so
imprinted in my mind unlike any other
physical space that large where
multiple times throughout my life a lot
of times when i i'm having trouble
sleeping what i'll do is i'll play an
entire round of golf on this 18 holes in
my head because i remember every hole
i could draw i could draw every hole for
you that's cool almost to the point of
every sand trap like if you were
imprisoned and like they they threw you
in a hole
that's this is how you go off in my head
cling to reality i would shoot so many
great scores in my head
but one of the things that this has done
for me is it's given me this incredible
desire to play the course again it's
been probably 15 years since i've played
the course okay and over the past 10
years since we've been in la multiple
times i've tried to set up my dad and my
brother and i playing keith hills and
something has always come up
uh i don't the last time it was like
week the trip got changed because of
covet or so i
so
i'm looking at the weather i'm thinking
about the fact that i just got exposed
by my wife but i'm also thinking
you know
uh maybe i'm immune to it
and also i'm gonna be outside the whole
day
um
so and i and i of course i told i told
my brother my dad was like i still want
to play golf uh jesse's got kovid we had
missionary sex last night i didn't tell
him that but i was like i'm pretty sure
i've been exposed
and they're both like we don't care like
whatever we're going to be playing golf
not a big deal okay
uh
and
the weather is getting bad like it looks
like it's gonna maybe rain us out i'm
like of course of course of course i'm
gonna get rained out i'm gonna get
covered i'm gonna not be able to play
the course you're in a bad headspace man
but um
the weather gods
who may or may not be just god uh
decided to smile upon us and it did not
rain at all
and
um
i played
i know no one cares about this but i'm
going to say it anyway
because i care about it i played so well
like it
the thing is is that you know if you
know
playing golf can be so frustrating but
when it's not frustrating it's almost as
good as missionary sex
and it is i mean it was just like i
could not believe how well i was hitting
it like you know i was just hitting
these drives in fact there was a guy who
uh was out there trying to get his he's
getting ready to do a qualifying thing
to become a not a tour pro but like a
pro shop pro you know every pro shop has
a pro
a person who is a professional golfer
who's not necessarily playing on the
tour but he's a pro golfer
and he and he was like we let him play
through because he was like
i got a qualifying round tomorrow and
i'm kind of getting in some practice
he saw my drive and he said
nice peace
peace nice peace and that
never heard we had never heard a golf
shot referred to as a piece i don't like
that but i'm beginning to do it more
often now i don't like that because a
pro potential pro is doing it anyway i
had an incredible time and i also was
like i don't even think i'm going to get
coveted man i mean can a guy who just
recently got coveted hit the ball like
this i don't think so
or maybe that's the only reason you
could yeah
i
go to sleep that night
and i wake up
i wake up in
chills
fever
headache
regret
i take a covet test of course it's
positive of course
i mean
i mean
you didn't really make a responsible
decision but
oh okay i'm just going to go on record
part of that what part of it the golf
part but playing outside
exposing your
your dad first of all
you know as well as i know uh covet is
behaves completely differently in north
carolina
yeah they don't think about it you know
in fact when it was their call when the
california people are like
hey i think i might have covid they're
like we don't care like it's just a
completely different perspective there
uh you know and and and
so
neither one of them got it i would say
my brother my dad did not get covered
okay my brother had already had it my
dad hasn't had it maybe he is immune
um yep and that's the statement that
makes people get it like that's not
that's how i mysticize this thing the
moment you start saying i haven't gotten
it i got it i kind of think i'm not
going to get it yeah that's right that's
when that's when you get it well but
here's the really interesting thing now
now the entire time that we're in north
carolina
everything has shifted
we're like we were planning on being in
this hotel for a little bit while jessie
is working on the house and then
we were going to
drive to the beach to spend fourth of
july with her family down at the beach
and then come back to la
uh and of course now it's like well
we're coveted buddies going to be in
this hotel room for who knows how long
the thing i failed to mention up to this
point is the nature of the hotel we're
staying in we're staying in a hotel
no the ceilings are plenty high but
we're staying in a hotel on franklin
street called the graduate which you
know about the graduate um
have i we stayed there
i've stayed at the government i've
stayed at the graduate in nashville the
graduate in providence rhode island it's
like a really cool hotel chain that like
takes
the themes of wherever it is and
incorporates it into a trendy sort of
hipstery situation
in this particular case it themes it
around carolina basketball oh
gross
which is almost as bad as covid
um
so i had coveted
but i'm also carolina blue and this oh
there's a
this just in my room there is a there
are side tables with
with rams on them there are pictures of
michael jordan and dean smith that i
cannot not look at
uh just outside the room there is a a
giant courtyard inside that is a literal
replica of the carolina court with two
basketball goals
and then like the front desk has like
a scoreboard with the final score from
the 1982 national championship whichever
one they want is not the place for you
and i thought i was going to be there
for a couple of days and i was like my
wife's a carolina grad i do let me just
say i have matured around this issue
over the past few years i think it's
just being in california where no one
cares about the rivalry but and also uh
nc state is doesn't you know carolina
doesn't really consider state i love
that you through everybody who who like
is really into this rivalry like you
just threw them all under the bus as
being immature uh no okay
what i'm saying is that as i have gotten
older
my
um belief that i or my willingness to
let
nc state's performance against carolina
or anyone else determine my happiness
from afar
has seemed to be
foolish i mean that's more of a
statement about nc state athletics than
it is about your maturity well but tying
your personal well-being to the
performance of a group of
20 year olds that you can't control does
seem immature
but listen i can't help it it's in my
blood i still care about sports i'm not
going to stop caring but i care a little
bit less than i used to
so i was able to somewhat enjoy
being because first of all before i knew
had coveted i did like walk around off
franklin street a little bit and i was
like this is a cool spot i gotta admit
um it's a cool spot you know this is a
cool college town it's a cool campus
whatever i just don't like them for a
lot of other reasons
but we once we knew we had coveted we
didn't leave we did not leave the hotel
room we told the front desk that we had
covered
we so we said we're going to need stuff
brought to us like we're going to be
doing they didn't have room service but
we're going to be doing like door dash
etc and we need somebody to bring that
to our door knock walk away so we're
taking it very seriously
uh stuck in this hotel room let me just
say
uh and i think this is probably a pretty
good time to for you to to because i'm
gonna start talking about what my
experience was um i had a great time in
hawaii
let's go back to that you ended up
getting coveted as well
not from me it was so strange like you
and i got it like almost at the same
time
being totally separate like after all of
this time of us avoiding it we both got
it independently of one another but so
did everyone everyone did i got it my
wife got it you got it your wife got it
locking it up getting it jen ended up
getting it jenna you got it independent
of both of us everybody's time together
everybody i know who made it until this
point without getting it got i don't i
know very few people christy came yeah
it's like you know we got back from
hawaii i got back from aspen and then
that week
my
my nieces came in from out of town first
time i was hanging out with them
for three days we went to universal
studios took them there
for the day and night had a blast next
day they flew back that night christy
starts feeling bad
and i think went ahead and tested the
positive my nieces
uh never ended up getting it but i think
we picked it up i mean you know i'm i'm
guessing it was at universal but she
started feeling bad that night after
universal yeah it can't happen that
quickly maybe it was earlier than that
yeah i'm pretty sure that's what
happened it like she had these flu-like
symptoms
um
body aches headache fever
like just being totally just
just grounded
in the bed you know just couldn't do
anything it
my throat was scratchy
never had a fever but like
i think it was a couple of days after
that
i
tested positive
around the time when i was going to come
back to work
so that's when things started getting
really frustrating because like we had
been gone on vacation kind of a
staggered vacation and then you get
covered a little bit after me and you
know you're waiting to test negative so
we can actually work again it's real you
know when you have so much had piled up
and was like ready to go
it was it was i really experienced
flashbacks to the beginning of the
pandemic and just remembering how
difficult it was to like
have so much that you felt like you
needed to do but like you couldn't i
couldn't do you could i could do so
little
so you you got better before me well but
we haven't talked about how bad it did
get it did yeah it was like for me you
have this attitude of like well i'm just
you know i'm fully vaccinated boosted
i'm just going to go ahead and get it
i you know let's just get this thing
over with because it won't be that big
of a deal anyway i mean when lando got
it actually
before our hawaii vacation
he didn't feel great for like a day and
a half and then
even 12. yeah he was 12. you know he he
was it was not a big deal beyond one day
and but yeah it was it was freaking for
a lot of people for a lot of people um
the original omicron wave which happened
around christmas was very mild for
everyone i knew who got it but this i'm
pretty sure
we both
all of us probably got ba four or bay
ba5 which is like the new variant right
yeah i would not characterize this as
mild i mean obviously i was like not
anywhere close to like going to the
hospital or anything but i just haven't
gotten sick
there were no there weren't any long
time with anybody but it was more of
like down with with christine with you
it was like flu symptoms well for me i
had a 103 point something fever which is
like that's that's like whoa you weren't
getting up there you might need to go to
the emergency room i wasn't gonna do
that but like that was what my fever was
chills were incredible it like the
headache was really intense and there
was probably like a four a 24 a 48 hour
period in which i would in the at night
time it would get like that and then i
would kind of be okay during the day
i recovered pretty quickly after that we
spent five about five days in this hotel
together
um
anyway i just say that like you know
it's not it's not it's not just a cold
it might be that for a lot of people and
i i hope it is from for most people but
it's not just a cold and now
it's also i mean obviously the thing
that from the from since we've learned
more about this that is the worrisome
thing is this long covid which is
affecting a a reasonably high percentage
of people are having these symptoms
some debilitating symptoms for an
extended period of time that's why this
it's just a cold for good about it it's
just is it worse the flu is just
a bullsh ignorant way to think about
this thing because it's just not
consistent with the truth about this
which is
uh this thing is gonna keep infecting
people and we don't know about these
long-term symptoms and uh this is not
like a small deal you can't it's all
it's just gonna become endemic and it's
gonna be fine hopefully that will happen
eventually but
both of us have been talking about and i
and i was kind of i says is this in my
head
but over the past few weeks it has
become an inescapable fact that i
something happened to my brain
like i got the covet brain
forgetting
very simple things that i obviously knew
thinking about something losing my train
of thought in the middle of something
hopefully these are temporary symptoms
that will go away
but i'm going to tell you right now it's
a real thing and it's a big freaking
deal like on a global scale that we will
be figuring out and reckoning with i
think the globe is going to get a little
dumber if we all get equally dumber then
it maybe maybe it's not that bad but
like it'll be more difficult to like
solve problems as a species now i don't
know what it says about me but i'm i've
had
i haven't had the fidelity of being able
to ascertain whether my brain fog is
just
a way of life or
if it's um
i mean
i don't know man i just think that
because i have name fright i can't
remember people's names
like
uh
we were talking about my therapy with my
family the other day and uh
yeah lily's like
what what's your therapist name and i
was like
i got this deer and the headlights
looking i couldn't remember my own
therapist's name
that kind of stuff has been happening to
me and uh and i'm like it was sudden and
it was totally tied to that experience
and again i'm trying not to you know his
name by the way because i still can't
remember it your original therapist no i
remember his name yeah i do my new
therapist
um
no i don't know i'm joking i i do
remember his name now you want to say it
don't say it
um so anyway i mean not to get on the
soapbox there but yeah it's like you
know it's not it ain't over i i feel
like it ain't over i do feel d having
gotten it and it not being fun at all
and not a breeze at all like i do feel
differently about it well and also it's
just like you know i don't
i don't want people to be going around
super scared and i understand all the
negative consequences to just like
living a life of fear and i don't want
to do that and i haven't been doing that
but it just kind of sucks that the
reality is
we can't just move on like everything's
normal that's why we still take these
precautions at mythical you know we get
tested every week and people wear masks
and it's not going to completely protect
you but and i think when you got to do
something when you do get it just giving
yourself permission to
recover give yourself time you know
instead of trying to push through which
are actually that's my that's that i
think that's good advice a safe advice i
think i'll leave it at that and it's
it's sound advice because trying to push
through physically or even mentally can
prolong your recovery okay
so we eventually get to a place where we
now we're still testing positive but
jesse's family like y'all come down to
the daggum beach and we're like well
we're gonna we're of course we're not
gonna get close to you and we're gonna
wear masks the whole time and of course
again north carolina they're like
okay whatever you want to do
we don't care
um so we go down there and
uh
i didn't thankfully i didn't have the
fatigue and so i was able i kind of felt
like i'm kind of i'm kind of back
fatigued was a bit a big part of it so
thank you head cold congestion and
fatigue
that were my those were my big things so
we were kind of like staying away from
everybody as well as we possibly could
thankfully none of them ended up getting
it
um
but you know on july
so on jul we had july 4th
a little celebration get together and
then july 5th was the day that i
announced the james and the shane
project i was like hey this is something
i've been working on here's a little
instagram post
so
on july 4th
during the day jesse and i were like hey
we haven't really been outside to take a
walk on the beach because we've been
trying to really take it easy and fully
recover but we both felt like we could
go out on the beach and take a walk
and so we go outside feeling like you'd
walk together this time yeah and we're
like walking side by side not in a
50-yard line
uh because things were great with us
um and we are walking down the beach in
literally the first it's so i i love i
love the north carolina coast i mean i'm
just going to be honest with you when
you go in july and you get in that water
oh you start thinking man like this is
better this is i'm sorry this the beach
at the beach is better here the beach is
better
than than california beaches let's just
be let's just be honest it may not be
it's bath water pretty or it's pristine
because it doesn't have like the
mountains and the cliffs and stuff but
there's nobody there you can when
families you you start feeling like you
might be too close to another family
when they're
a hundred feet away you know what i'm
saying like there's just so much you
don't have to tell me i talk to my dad
every week yeah right
so
but the first little family group that
we come to recognizes me
oh rhett
um
hey can we get a picture and i said
yeah
i do want to let you know and i didn't
have my mask on because i'm walking
outside i'm like
uh
i'm recovering from covet so i don't
want you to get too close
okay
i was like i didn't want to be like
don't get too close to me without
telling him and i didn't want to let him
get close to me
because i'm trying to be respectful and
so we ended up getting a picture and
this guy and this girl were kind of on
like you know i tell some fans i have
herpes sometimes yeah just don't touch
my lips
uh there's they're probably like two
people you know it's a weird picture i'm
sure i didn't see it but i'm sure it's a
weird picture probably taken in
landscape given the fact that they're
this far from me
it's like you're photo bombing there
i thought nothing of it
you know it's a weird a slightly weird
interaction because i'm like don't touch
me don't get close to me because i'm
recovering from covid
and then the reason i said that the next
day i share on instagram about james and
the shame is because
i got this comment on my instagram post
i'm not gonna say who it's from
i actually met this dude on the beach
yesterday and he seemed annoyed that i
recognized him don't meet your heroes i
guess
ha
seemed annoyed dude
i told you that i was recovering from
covet
i mean i almost responded to this
comment but then i just was like i don't
i'm gonna wait and we're gonna talk
about covet on the podcast
um
but i told you that i had covered that's
why i didn't you think i made that up
let me read it not so i can say the
person's name out loud but
i'm going to
do yeah yep yeah you don't have to say
the person's name out loud i've actually
met this dude
and
and also sound like a fan
well
it's weird it it had it had to have been
is the only person i met on the beach
the day before
so he wasn't like the significant other
he was the one who said rhett oh
so anyway
thanks thanks a lot for that
dude
um should have just given him covet
don't meet your heroes they might have
covet and tell you to not get close to
them
don't be so annoyed about it the
[ __ ]
what don't be so annoyed uh him he
shouldn't be so annoyed about it is that
what you mean no you man why you so
annoyed
well you know it's like i
because i actually had a conversation
with this dude about what you're
commenting about he seemed annoyed then
too well i think the reason that it gets
on my nerves so much i know why it gets
on your nose no it's because like all it
takes is one little story like that for
people to be like oh you know you got
that guy's actually an [ __ ] in person
you know and so i'm i don't just i'm not
just nice to people because of a i have
a reputation to maintain i'm nice to
people because i am nice to people
and i also appreciate if people want to
come up and if they're fans of the show
like i really i really appreciate that
that day on the uh
the the four plane day where i'm in
these airports and i'm rushing around
wondering if i'm going to get lots of
people came up to me that day
and i was like i'm having a really
shitty day but i'm not going to let them
know it you know what i'm saying so i
was like put on a smile and had a good
interaction um
i just thought that was uh especially
um that's a tough one man
you know par for the course with the
life you're living but it was kind of
sort of the proper way to wrap up the
vacation because that's the kind of
thing that it just characterizes the
whole experience but i will say
that coming back
fully recovering except for some brain
fog
and some forgetfulness whatever is
happening
and then like i you know
it's really nice when you can get back
home
and be happy
a to be in your own home
and be like i really like the home that
we have i like the the home that we have
built not just the home itself the house
itself i love my toilet uh
but
the people
in my home
um
and then to have a job that you want to
come back to
there's a lot to there's a lot to be
thankful for when your vacation sucks
yeah yeah well it does put that into
perspective because i think that there's
you know plenty of people who are like
man i hate my job so i'm all i do is
look forward to a vacation and then when
i'm on vacation all i do is dread the
fact that i'm going to have to go back
to work
it's nice to be like you know i'm ready
i'm ready to get back at it it has been
tough coming back though after
everything being delayed because of
our especially me being sick it delayed
our whole production schedule that's
it's been tough to try to because we had
to cram everything in
i wasn't you know it's like jumping into
the deep end
yeah
vacation everything has been stacked on
itself
um
which is why we're going on another
vacation we're going on like a long
weekend vacation we're about to go back
to colorado
we're going to meet our college friends
yeah and we're gonna go whitewater
rafting yeah if we survive this will
make another great podcast
yeah if this is the last podcast it's
because uh
i don't know either one of our college
friends killed us
or something bad happened whitewater
rafting well i did i have said on our
group thread that this is like the
perfect setup for like a horror movie
you know or a thriller because it's like
you get together with your college
friends that you haven't really hung out
with in this fashion in 20 years
start getting topless then that's when
you know something bad somebody's gonna
die yep
uh so yeah we might have an incredible
story to tell next time all right but in
the meantime you gotta wreck yeah go
whale watching
yeah i never thought i wanted to go
whale watching because
yeah i just think about everything but
seeing a whale assuming that you won't
see one but man even in the worst
vacation ever
you saw
you saw all those whales now i've set
the standard i saw two blue whales and
they did the tail thing go well
so i can't guarantee that you'll have
that kind of experience but i will say
you should dress warmly definitely take
anti-nausea medicine i took dramamine
still got a little i started to feel a
little bit seasick on the way out but i
was like i was going to breathe deeply
and get through this and i did it was
fine
um all right solid that would be my only
concern for the neil family there might
be some
some sickness yeah in my encounter maybe
i'll see one when i'm going scuba diving
that'd be great that would be awesome
yeah go whale watching all right we'll
speak at you next week
your biscuits
and of course you can always call and
let us know what your reaction is to uh
listening to the latest episode one
eight seven seven what is it is it eight
eight eight
yeah
one eight eight eight earpod one
kobe bryant hey rhett mike this is jake
from albuquerque just listening to link
recall his family vacation in maui and
uh it was very fitting because i was
there around this time last year where i
proposed to my girlfriend at the top of
haleakala
and now we are set to be married and
we're actually flying out to greece this
week for that marriage so
i don't know link if you're just
following me around maybe you need to go
to greece next year i can tell you all
about that trip when i get back thanks
for all the content that you put out
there everything's great love dispatches
from myrtle beach can't wait to
recognize your dad hi written link it's
haley
i just wanted to
come on and say
that i am just so excited for brett's
solo music project i'm just so excited
that you guys are being able to do um
separate things you know i also love
link's podcast with his dad and it's
just been awesome to see you guys branch
out and do separate things but also um
stay together and do be your funny stuff
hey rhett and link so i have a friend
named keefer that's not why i'm calling
i'm calling because i have a bottle of
kefir in front of me for the very first
time which i have just tried and it's
all because of you because i've never
heard of this in my entire life first
opinions i got the blueberry i think it
tastes pretty good it just reminds me
really of liquefied yogurt
which is fine and i'll let you know if
it starts making me happy
to watch more ear biscuits click on the
playlist on the right to watch the
previous episode of your biscuits click
on the playlist to the left and don't
forget to click on the circular icon to
subscribe if you prefer to listen to
this podcast it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms thanks for
being your mythical best
[Music]